hey it's Donna here with some welcome
news for console gamers the fulbright
company celebrated in the first person
game gone home with launch on consoles
in fall 2014 in a press release the
game's writer on designer Steve gainer
said ever since we released gone home on
PC we've had people asking us when is it
coming to console we've been looking and
looking for the right partner to help us
and finally after much searching
midnight city fit the bill when asked
which consoles the game will be coming
to on Twitter midnight city responded
we're not releasing any more details
other than coming to consoles at the
moment gamespot awarded gone home in 9.5
in our review in august 2013 the game
tells the story of a young woman who
comes home after a year in europe to
find an empty house and then must
unravel the mystery of why she is now
alone midnight city also announced today
they'll be publishing the charming
halloween themed costume quest to buy
double fine productions coming halloween
this year to PC and consoles so good
news from midnight city then stay tuned
to gizbot calm for more coverage of gone
home and costume quest to
you